Надя савченко могла б панчоху і кульгати
карузо звивина не палить я не в українці
в Росії
пари канони та адвокат марк фейгін питання
хвала не викликав чи навчити і заході
так уже нагадав і про на пк і дизельними
менших братів кремля євросоюзу яка у
всі сторони розвивати ці позитивніші
кроку та в ікону ось і мінську біля води та
включена із забав я за ним ще до
побачення у серця ручників та за 3 мани
хосеп пов'язаних із конфліктом на сході
україни якщо довго їх довіряй
зарядити їх поодиноку брудні ланки
астапченко не вожу його участі в і
канальний мінських виродок і травня стати
імпульсом для їх повної імплементації ми
за клацаємо і люттю звивини тусик
повний інших таусі брики худий ремонт на
законну
адвокати та наших братів кремля ситуації
сюди подалі вам про [ __ ] його своїх
підзахисних на командує мовляв травня так
у будинкового нести золоту допог і кольору
його вирішити про ітан ще до них
клієнтів в одну з експертами мат
оптимісти чого киньте перспективи звала
не інших за ручників звір лівші
савченко москва на мага це подати
сигнал я до України так і за ходу права
відкриттів до діалогу та компромісу в
означають постере хочу
Однак експерти миють сум не в схемі.
заяку і звернули савченко з проти
менших братів кремля
i don't think вони думаю що це може
повторила то себе багата разил можна його
1 год 2 в ж ходж а тому що україна моя
обмажу кільки з політичних арештантів
яких можна за пропан вати на обмін
а ось так само і тому що саме це побачення
збилося відклав його телефонний розмова
маєш путіним олландом і меркель праворуч
савченко вас кути його від льотчиця
стала символом конфлікту між україною
і росією у
інструментом для лідери о бок краєм для
звір мене інших бран темно думка чи вона
так вони мати кого товар вид-во сонячну
політики штефана майстра за родом цим
потрібна політична воля вишивок і
ревнощі у Росії
просто харчування в тому ще будуть корабель
це тег барана не в тему
москва на де слова сигнал що я хочу
російська сторона омоте ми що система
напрокат досвідом санкція будеш мене
кого підходу study russian 3 травня 3
хочеш я хочу не викупу чому ви небу
скажу тобі явно небо
д обидва заправку ну і тинчурина зору
з'явилася і
в team експерти пари каноні для звір
мене українських брянців потрібно не
найкраща політична воля до ремесла
росії
all і так вже it is хто вага його дати його
харчування збоку заходу